[Musica]
uno dei parametri con il quale viene
giudicato il mio lavoro è che le persone
che hanno assistito allo spettacolo
dicano che bello dovrai quindi avere una
formula un catalogo di cose belle che
sono certo che possono servire a questo
scopo
la realtà però è profondamente diversa
perché ogni mattina mi sveglio nel
panico perché so che quello che devo
fare
dovrà essere bello per qualcuno dovrò
aiutare o guidare un team alla ricerca
della bellezza come se la bellezza fosse
qualcosa semplicemente da selezionare
come un'immagine all'interno di un
catalogo in più la realtà in cui opero
che appunta bajur while the show noi ci
occupiamo di creare spettacoli e i
nostri clienti sono in giro in tutto il
mondo è difficile che lavoriamo in
italia è più facile che ci rivolti al
rivolgiamo a realtà estere
quindi il senso della bellezza di questo
pubblico è diverso dal nostro dovrei
quindi avere un catalogo per ognuno di
questi paesi
come fare quindi a toccare le corde
delle emozioni di un pubblico così
diverso da noi
la risposta che mi do è riuscire a
creare un linguaggio universale qualcosa
che riesca a trascendere le barriere
culturali e di linguaggio e il modo per
fare questo sicuramente appunto è lo
studio la ricerca e vi vorrei raccontare
un esempio appunto che ha riferito
all'ultima esperienza che ho fatto la
direzione creativa della cerimonia di
chiusura dei giochi asiatici che si sono
tenuti in turkmenistan illuminista n'è
uno dei paesi più assurdi e oscuri e
sicuramente sconosciuti al mondo
il comitato olimpico asiatico ha deciso
di organizzare le olimpiadi
i giochi aimag che sono questi giochi
asiatici
quando ci si approccia una cerimonia di
questo tipo il paese ospitante organizza
un comitato culturale che ti aiuta a
appunto farei ricercati aiutati
accompagna alla ricerca di quella che è
la cultura del posto questi eventi
queste cerimonie sono qualcosa di
importantissimo per loro sono una
vetrina che serve per mostrarsi al mondo
per dire io esisto questa è la mia
cultura hanno quasi una funzione
didattica
volte questo comitato quindi era formato
da direttori artistici del luogo enti
governativi artisti locali e ovviamente
per me andare a lavorare con persone di
questo tipo è una cosa che mi interessa
di più quello che viene fatto però alle
volte da questi comitati è creare una
sorta di perimetro creativo all'interno
del quale tutti nuovi e che rischia di
creare una visione un po cristallizzata
di quel paese cioè ci sono cose che
bisogna dire c'è una bibliografia di
riferimento ci sono artisti da citare
tutte cose utilissime ovviamente ma è
difficile volte trovare quel tipo di
scintilla che può accendere qualcosa in
te che dica ok questa cosa la voglio
raccontare una delle cose che ci ha
fatto fare nei nostri sopralluoghi nelle
nostre visite linee luogo è stato una
full immersion siamo stati presi portati
a vedere decine di spettacoli decine di
compagni e tutti i siti archeologici del
paese i musei
insomma un vero e proprio tour de force
e vederlo adesso fa quasi sorridere
perché immaginatevi che ci trovavamo a
volte in teatri vuoti perché era
soltanto per noi lo spettacolo per me
per il team creativo che mi accompagnava
o questi poveri attori si trovavano
dovrà fare due tre spettacoli al giorno
perché facevano il best of della loro
compagnia
insomma chi era veramente una situazione
divertente ed era un onore avere questo
tipo di cura da parte loro però
rischiava di creare con la situazione
che dicevo prima una sorta di catalogo
da cui selezionare delle immagini da
prendere
in una di queste serate tra il pubblico
siamo entrati in contatto con un gruppo
di cantanti di un coro locale erano
delle babouche che c'è nelle donne di
oltre 60 anni e il calore con le quali
si sono avvicinati a noi mi ha subito
incuriosito perché ci hanno raccontato
cose che nessuno ci stava raccontando in
quel momento hanno iniziato a parlarci
di canti tradizionali che non
conoscevamo di storie che non
conoscevamo e quindi ho chiesto di
organizzare un incontro con loro lo
passano l'intera giornata con queste
donne
la domanda è stata accolta ovviamente
con stupore perché la risposta è stata
ma come ti stiamo organizzando tutto
queste sono le cose che devi guardare da
qua devi prendere il bello non c'è
niente di interessante lino sono neanche
professioniste probabilmente e ho
insistito e sono riuscito ad organizzare
quest'incontro grazie
al direttore del comitato culturale che
era il direttore del teatro nazionale di
ashgabat tale kakà jean veil di cui poi
vi parlerò e questo incontro quindi
diventata una cosa ufficiale appena è
diventato ufficiale si è perso un po di
quel tipo di spontaneità di cui vi ho
parlato prima che aveva suscitato il
nostro interesse ancora abbiamo sentito
le storie che stanno sentendo un po di
giorni le canzoni eccetera quindi siamo
riusciti poi a trovare un contatto che
la cosa fondamentale quando parli con
artisti e questi dialoghi fatti di
grandi gesti traduttori che provano a
starci dietro perché lavorare
linguistica enorme e è successa una cosa
magica con quel giorno
una di queste donne iniziato a cantarci
una canzone che era una ninna nanna una
ninna nanna che era in una lingua che
non era il trucco meno corrente non era
russo era qualcosa che era una lingua
appunto post turca del passato che lei
conosceva perché sono madrid e la
cantava la madre della madre alla
cantava lei insomma era qualcosa che noi
di cui non abbiamo trovato nessuna
registrazione e oltre a quel momento ma
da subito acceso qualcosa in noi che ha
detto ma questa cosa non la dobbiamo
mescolare dobbiamo capire meglio cos'è è
stato uno di quei momenti come nei film
no che fu l'occhio di bue va su una
persona tutto il resto è buio e quello
che lei stava cantando ha mosso in tutti
noi qualcosa e appuntamento e restava
tanto parlare con loro perché loro
avevano visto il loro paese cambiare
avevano visto loro paese passare dall
unione sovietica al paese in cui è oggi
quindi mi stavano veramente raccontando
qualcosa che non poteva essere nei libri
era la discendenza di piccole sacche di
resistenza culturale che derivavano
dalle
diverse famiglie tribali della zona e
vorrei farvi sentire questo
[Musica]
[Risate]
avevamo registrato questa cosa quindi è
veramente prezioso avere questo
documento oggi perché sono non ci
avrebbe creduto
quindi poi noi abbiamo elaborato questa
questo momento è la valanga creativa che
si scatena quando si trova qualcosa di
interessante di bello io avevo questo
momento nello show dove parlavo della
bellezza della natura e mi immaginavo
questa grandissima onda d'acqua che
entrasse sul palcoscenico e volevo che
ci fosse qualcuno a chiamare quest'acqua
per me è l'acqua era la vita era
qualcosa che nutre ovviamente avrebbe
poi generato tutto il resto dello
spettacolo e la ninna nanna
probabilmente ha toccato reminescenze di
cui ancora non mi rendo conto ma la
ninna nanna è qualcosa che leghiamo alla
genitorialità in questo caso la
maternità
abbiamo creato insomma questa donna onda
questa donna acqua che era una grande
madre che è diventata qualcosa di quasi
divina oserei dire e e l'abbiamo messa
sul palco e ho voluto ricreare la stessa
sensazione che ho vissuto in quella
stanza cioè quell occhio di bue di cui
ho parlato prima allora ho fatto una
cosa che è difficile fare in cerimonie
di questo tipo cioè avere soltanto una
persona che attraversava il palco da
destra a sinistra per quasi due minuti e
tutta l'attenzione su di lei volevo che
ci fosse soltanto lei in quel in quel
momento dello spettacolo ed era
sicuramente la cosa rischiosa due minuti
di questo sono un'infinità nei tempi del
live show ma ha funzionato e dopo
diciamo parte del processo prima della
messa in scena in una delle ultime
riunioni che ho fatto con appunto il
direttore del teatro nazionale che come
dicevo era a capo di questo comitato
culturale
mi ha raccontato che era in macchina
stava facendo un viaggio con sua sorella
stava ascoltando le musiche dello show
perché ovviamente avevano tutto prima di
andare in scena e si è trovato a
commuoversi davanti a questa musica
e allora lì ho capito che quello che
aveva mosso me che con onestà dovevo per
forza cavalcare perché aveva mosso
qualcosa bisognava percorrere o
bisognava fare in modo che si portasse
in scena aveva mosso anche lui che era
così diverso da me ed ero sicuro a
quando ho sentito questo che avrebbe
mosso anche il pubblico che aveva
davanti
ed ha funzionato e adesso vi vorrei far
vedere un estratto di di quello che è
successo
[Musica]
questo era un estratto e vi ho
raccontato questo esempio perché questo
è l'esempio di come andare a cercare e
trovare la bellezza in qualcosa che non
deve essere per forza per forza
standardizzato per forza dei libri non
deve essere per forza una citazione di
qualcuno di importante o qualcosa di
estremamente bello in un senso canonico
del termine non era la canzone e sa che
mi interessava era quello che
rappresentava quella donna era la
purezza di quel momento e questo è uno è
appunto dei tratti peculiari del nostro
lavoro e del riuscire a raccontare
qualcosa che possa veramente toccare le
corde di tutti è quello che abbiamo
fatto è stato creare questo tipo di
linguaggio universale in questo caso
quando sono stato contattato per questo
talk mi sono reso conto che una risposta
alla domanda cosa muove la bellezza non
ce l'avevo quindi anche lì nel panico mi
sono messo su google cosa muove la
bellezza però ha detto forse non è il
caso di venire oggi con una citazione di
l'once quindi permettetemi di divagare
due anni fa ero in viaggio in giappone
ero con la mia compagna lulù ciao lulù è
una delle tappe obbligate era il monte
fuji
ci siamo trovati però davanti a una
delle giornate più nebbiose che abbia
mai visto e quindi non so cosa ne
penserebbe nives di me ma abbiamo non
abbiamo scalato anni e se abbiamo dovuto
cercare qualcos'altro da fare per puro
caso ci siamo imbattuti in questo museo
che era la casa laboratorio di shikoku
boter il ciclo kubota non lo conoscevamo
è questo ricamatore di key money che è
scomparso nel 2003 e è importantissimo
in giappone ed è riuscito a trascendere
la sua arte da ricamatore di qimonda
diventare una persona veramente
importante nella nell'arte
internazionale e questo per due motivi
di cui non due motivi però ci sono due
esperienze nella sua vita che se come
vale la pena raccontare oggi la prima è
che a vent'anni negli anni trenta si
imbatte in un museo in un kimono creato
con una tecnica che era andata perduta
che si chiama tucci ghana era una
tecnica per colorare kimoni che era
stata perduta nel xvi secolo non c'era
più traccia
quando lui vede questo kimono dice per
me è stato come per la prima volta veder
a colori passano gli anni e pochi anni
dopo quando a 30 anni scopre la seconda
guerra mondiale viene mandato nel fronte
perde in battaglia e viene deportato in
siberia e viene mandato nei campi di
prigionia siberia e racconta di questa
esperienza che una dell'esperienza
ovviamente più tragiche con esseri umani
che tutta l'umanità possa vivere
racconta come ogni mattina lui si
svegliasse e c'era questo sole davanti a
questo campo di prigionia che sorgeva
sulle distese innevate della seab i raid
era la cosa più bella che aveva mai
visto il sole questo rosso questa
potenza incredibile della bellezza che
aveva di fronte è stata l'unica ragione
per lui quello che lui racconta che se
sopravvissuto è stato grazie alla voglia
di poter raccontare un giorno quel tipo
di bellezza
finisce la guerra sopravvive e tornò in
giappone decide immediatamente che
dedicherà la sua vita alla riscoperta
della tecnica di cui ho parlato prima
come solo un giapponese sa fare
dedicateci negli anni questa cosa e
quando a 60 anni capisce come come
funziona quella tecnica la fa sua si
chiamerà poi questa tecnica e cxc ghana
e inizia la sua più grande opera che si
chiama e symphony of light questo qua il
primo kimono che è riuscito a fare con
quel tipo di tecnica e inizia a
quest'opera che è un'opera una
composizione di 80 kimoni adesso ne
scorrono alcuni o di 80 kimoni che
rappresentano la bellezza della vita la
bellezza delle stagioni la bellezza
della natura e per finirla lui sapeva
che avrebbe dovuto vivere fino a 100
anni perché per fare questi kimoni ci
vuole più di un anno non è una cosa che
si può fare in un team di lavoro
esagerato e è una cosa profondamente
artigianale non riesce a finire la sua
opera ma il mondo dell'arte durante la
creazione dei primi 40 si accorge di lui
e esplode e addirittura lui è stato il
primo artista vivente ad essere esposte
allo smithsonian nel 97 a 80 anni perché
vi sto raccontando questo vorrei farvi
vedere questo kimono che per lui è il
raggiungimento più alto della sua arte
della sua espressività si chiama sun il
sole la potenza della bellezza di quello
che aveva visto 50 anni prima in quel
campo di prigionia ha mosso
successivamente i suoi 50 anni di vita
umana ed artistica quello che era
riuscito a farlo sopravvivere in quell
esperienza è riuscito anche a muovere
successivamente tutte
la sua vita e questo esempio è la mia
risposta alla domanda di oggi cosa muove
la bellezza questo è quello che muove la
bellezza e questo per me quello che
chiude il cerchio la bellezza genera e
muove il cambiamento
la bellezza ti permette di creare
qualcosa che fa cambiare tutto quello
che è in cambiabile c'è un collettivo di
scrittori wu ming che sono italiani non
giapponese altre mente sempre
ossessionato ha detto una volta che gli
artisti il completo degli artisti è
quello di forzare l'immaginazione verso
il cambiamento forzare l'immaginazione
verso il cambiamento è una frase
fortissima perché come si fa a forzare
l'immaginazione cosa vuol dire forzare
un atto cosi violento ma invece no con
la bellezza che è l'unico strumento che
noi abbiamo per allargare il nostro
campo allargare i nostri confini che
possono essere appunto geografici o
contenutistici ma forzare il cambiamento
attraverso l'immaginazione è l'unica
cosa che è possibile fare tramite un
atto d'arte e tramite la bellezza e
quindi questo il messaggio che vorrei
condividere con voi oggi
[Applauso]